hilfen an diejenigen die es gar nicht
nötig haben der fehlgriff aus dem hause
hp steht dabei besonders im fokus die
gasanlage jetzt wird heftig und auch
hektisch korrigiert streit um gasanlage
was muss habeck ändern jetzt in der
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
hier im studio julia löhr ist bereits
wirtschaftskorrespondentin im
hauptstadtbüro in berlin und sie sind
von der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung
faz jörg neubauer ist ehemaliger oder
bis vor kurzem bürgermeister von
augustusburg in sachsen gewesen und seit
wenigen wochen sind sie landrat im
landkreis mittelsachsen sie waren
zeitweise spd-mitglied jetzt sind sie
wieder parteilos matthias urbach ist
stellvertretender chefredakteur des
verbraucherportals finanz tippt de und
sebastian bohley ist bei uns der ex
leiter energie umwelt industrie des
deutschen industrie und
handelskammertages genannt oder in der
abkürzung die ihk neubauer fühlt sich
auf der kommunalen ebene sie waren
bürgermeister jetzt in sie landrat vor
möglichen engpässen in der gasversorgung
jetzt sogar auf den und den blick auf
den kommenden winter einigermaßen
geschützt er ist kein thema bei uns hat
mich das sonst erst mal im sächsischen
landkreistag zum thema die fragezeichen
sind ziemlich groß ist es eigentlich
keine aufgabe der kommunalen ebene
aber wir suchen natürlich auch nach
antworten und es wäre schön wir hätten
jetzt hat meine idee
denn ich glaube wir müssen den leuten
mal langsam sagen wo es hingeht und
diese diese unsicherheit die da grad
herrscht die ist ein ernsthaftes problem
es bringt ja unser politisches system so
mit sich dass die
kommunalpolitiker wie sie ja ganz nah an
den bürgern sind die
was treibt die menschen um gas umlage
ich habe eine cd ist das thema gas
umlage an sich ist wahrscheinlich gar
nicht dass er das thema das wir müssen
sehen wo sich die abschläge hin
entwickeln wenn ich meine häuserzeile in
der ich selber wohne ich habe jetzt auch
mal ein abschlag bleiberecht bekommen
mit 5 600 euro im monat
vorher waren es glaube ich irgendwas um
die 120
ich bin jetzt nicht bedürftig aber wenn
ich zurücktrete und sehe mein nachbar
der pendels panels ans band zu
volkswagen da habe ich schon bei der
benzinpreis diskussion gefragt warum er
arbeiten führten noch ein haus weiter wo
ein rentner und da fehlt mir momentan
ernsthaft die idee und wir reden über
gas wir reden nicht über strom das ist
die nächste katastrophe die sich das
zusammengehört und wir brauchen jetzt
glaube ich endlich eine antwort und es
gibt viele modelle die auf dem tisch
liegen die mir jetzt ich bin kein
energieexperte aber die mir logisch
erscheinen aber wir brauchen jetzt
einfach mal ein vorwärts damit er ruhe
reinkommen weil die menschen sind
berechtigterweise sehr unruhig aber das
ist mir ein satz muss sagen
privathaushalte sind das eine ich habe
heute das erste mal mit dem
bürgermeister gesprochen dessen stadt in
kleinen stadtwerk hat die haben richtige
probleme also dass darüber redet ja
momentan noch von löhr mit der
ursprünglichen idee einer gasanlage
sowie dass sich robert habeck gedacht
hat er ja ganz offensichtlich ins klo
gegriffen was hat ihn da eigentlich
umgetrieben war er da zu blauäugig zu
vertrauensselig zu schlecht informiert
glaube es war einfach der hektik dieser
tage im juni geschuldet also dass klar
war konzerne wie juniper das ist ja vor
allem der große eine gasimporteur der
jetzt in großen finanziellen
schwierigkeiten ist dem geht das geld
aus und es muss schnell eine lösung her
und dann wurde halt fieberhaft überlegt
was macht man jetzt am besten die eine
option wäre gewesen zu sagen also die
importeure können ihre mehrkosten
weitergeben an die ihre eigenen kunden
damit sie halt eben keine verluste mehr
schreiben dann wären aber halt gerade
die kunden die dann an juniper dran
hängen also an dem russischen gas
besonders betroffen gewesen andere von
anderen importeuren die vielleicht schon
andere gasquellen habe ein bisschen
weniger also wurde entschieden okay wir
machen das jetzt über alle gaskunden und
das ist dann zumindest ein bisschen
gerechter und die lasten im einzelnen
sind ein bisschen geringer aber
natürlich wie sie sagen es sind jede
menge details nicht berücksichtigt
worden oder sie sind gesehen worden aber
es gibt noch keine lösung dafür heute
wurden jetzt einige nachbesserungen
vorgestellt aber es bestehen weiter
nämlich ganz durch glaube ich sogar das
muss ja auch alles macht der
eigentlichen kostentreiber das ist ja
nicht die gasanlage sondern das sind
diese exorbitanten markt preise für gas
und damit auch für strom ist denn da ein
ende der preisentwicklung zu erkennen
die speicher sind ja jetzt einigermaßen
voll
wie schätzen sie das ein
aus sicht der verbraucherschützer sie
kommen ja mit einem auch mit einem
vollen gastsprecher nicht welchen winter
komplett ja das sollte man da sollte man
sich keine illusionen hingeben das wird
eine enge sache werden und ich fand
immer die gas umlagen debatte auch etwas
merkwürdig weil er geht es am ende um
zweieinhalb cent jetzt nach der neuen
mehrwertsteuer 309 mehrwertsteuer
beschluss dazu und wenn man das mal
vergleich mit den erhöhung mit dem es
gerade zu tun haben da geht es eher so
um 11 13 cent oder so zum beispiel die
stadtwerke wie es waren haben gerade
eine erhöhung zum oktober angekündigt in
dieser größenordnung ist bis 13 cent
insgesamt im durchschnitt sind wir
gerade so bei 18 cent pro
kilowattstunde gas ja für den endkunden
und da waren wir vor zwei jahren noch
bei 6 cent vor einem jahr bei sieben
cent das heißt sie haben gegenüber vor
zwei jahren jetzt schon eine
verdreifachung neubauer hat mit der
verfünffachung sondern persönlichen
gasrechnung besonders viel pech gehabt
ja das ist übrigens wirklich sehr
interessant also dass die
verbraucherzentrale nrw hat in
ich habe im juni oder im juli war das
eine erhebung bei grundversorgern in den
nordrhein westfalen gemacht und dabei
kam heraus dass ist das also gaspreise
gab von etwas über 6 cent bis 43 cent in
der grundversorgung und das sind auch
leute die das oft gar nicht die sich da
nicht viele gedanken drüber machen und
ich kann wirklich nur jeden verbraucher
also eigentlich jeden bürger jede
bürgerin auffordern schaut jetzt mal auf
eure auf eure gasrechnung und wenn die
sie nicht selber kriegt fragt eure
vermieter wo steht ihr da eigentlich
weil es ist einfach so das wird richtig
richtig hart da geht es um hunderte euro
im monat ja auch nicht im jahr und das
ist für viele menschen sehr sehr schwer
aufzubringen und ich glaube was in der
debatte wirklich vor allem fehlt ist zu
denken an die die unteren einkommen ja
die unteren 20 prozent der einkommen wo
etwa drei viertel zwei drittel der
ausgaben etwa festliegen in miete heizen
ernährung das heißt wir haben auch gar
keine ausweichmöglichkeiten da kommt
jetzt einfach kommt dieses dieses geld
an und ich weiß nicht ob sie den
vorschlag von der diakonie ich fand das
sehr
bezeichnet den sie mit dem db
zusammengerechnet haben die gesagt haben
dass man diesen menschen 100 euro im
monat geben soll sechs monate lang und
jetzt erst mal das schlimmste abzuwenden
und die haben das eine soziale notlage
nationaler tragweite genannt die man
quasi ausrufen müssen um so eine
maßnahme zu rechtfertigen und was ich
daran ganz schön finde ist dass diese
wortwahl einmal so ein bisschen klar
macht in was für einer besonderen
situation wir uns gerade befinden
mit den beträgen die wir bisher gehört
habe wohl hunderte oder tausende
zusätzlicher kosten damit kommen die
industrie nicht zurecht das gibt es ganz
andere beträge die einzelne
industriebetriebe und nicht nur die
energieintensiven da beraten sind macht
denn diese grad umlage die ja eben auch
die betriebe bezahlen müssen überhaupt
sind aus ihrer sicht oder sollte man die
unterstützung der
zunächst mal der gas verkäufer der
gashändler auf eine andere weise
sicherstellen die dann sozusagen auch
privathaushalte die unternehmen
entlastet also ich möchte zunächst noch
einmal betonen dass die lage wirklich
dramatisch ist herr ober hat ist ja
gerade schon betont wir wissen nicht ob
wir über den winter kommen wir wissen es
auch beim strom nicht was noch alles
passieren kann das kommt ja als
zusätzliche risiko faktor dazu und dann
haben wir diese exorbitanten strom und
gaspreise die wirklich viele unternehmen
und da auch nicht nur in der industrie
vor massive probleme stellen wir sehen
jetzt schon reihenweise
geschäftsaufgaben von unternehmen auch
nicht nur in der industrie also durchaus
auch im handels und dienstleistungs
bereich ich habe erst heute mit einer
bäckerin telefoniert die mir erzählt hat
na ja wohl eigentlich müsste ich die
brezel nicht mehr für 150 anbieten
sondern eigentlich für neun euro das hat
natürlich nicht nur direkt mit ihren
strom- und gaskosten zu tun das hat
natürlich indirekt denn das mehl ist
teurer geworden und der zucker ist
teurer geworden
wir sprechen über mindestlohn also
kommen natürlich auch noch faktoren dazu
die jetzt nicht energie bedingt sind
aber das ist die realität in vielen
unternehmen und andere formulieren die
dann ist auch für sie die gasanlage gar
nicht mehr so die frage sind die
marktpreise für gas die berater es kommt
noch oben drauf aber es macht eigentlich
den kohl nicht mehr effekt diese gas und
mathe macht den kohl für manche
unternehmen auch sehr sehr fett blicken
wir mal zurück vor anderthalb jahren
sind größeres industrieunternehmen und
also relativ viel gas verbraucht haben
dann haben sie in endkundenpreis also
gasbeschaffungskosten netzentgelte
umlagen von etwa 25 euro je
megawattstunde so hoch ist alleine
aktuell die geplante umlage ungefähr auf
den blues - auf den betrag werde näher
kommen das ist jetzt so lange die hohen
gasbeschaffungskosten insgesamt sind so
lange kein problem solange sie im
europäischen wettbewerb stehen und ihre
wettbewerber in europa eben auch den
hohen gaspreisen ausgesetzt sind
jetzt kommt aber diese gas umlage als
nationales sonderlast oben drauf und
dann kann es dazu führen dass einzelne
firmen massive probleme kriegen ich
mache ein beispiel dazu auch heute
telefoniert werden uns glühen natürlich
die drähte
papierfabrik drei standorte in
deutschland der wird durch die gasanlage
mit etwa 150 millionen euro zusätzlich
belastet das verteuert sein produkt und
zehn prozent und das kann er im
wettbewerb nicht durchsetzen das heißt
er steht dann wenn das jetzt alles so
beschlossen wird vor dem ende seiner
produktion in deutschland und ob er dann
wieder aufmacht das ist die große frage
sehen jetzt einige sachen aufgezählt
werden wir gleich noch genauer
besprechen was das gerade eben auch für
die unternehmen nicht nur für die
privathaus im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium rat habe
scheint so langsam gedämmert zu haben in
den letzten tagen wahrscheinlich auch
mit beeinflussung von außen was er da
angerichtet hat deswegen hat er heute
auch auf der kabinettsklausur in
meseberg nördlich von berlin sich noch
einmal zur gas umlage geäußert und das
was er da gesagt hat dass wenn wir uns
jetzt nochmal an wie schaffen wir es bei
der gasanlage dafür zu sorgen dass die
unternehmen die auch aus meiner sicht
unberechtigterweise jetzt die ihre
ansprüche gestellt haben die nicht
erfüllt bekommen das sind diese
trittbrettfahrer unternehmen und ich
denke wir haben einen guten vorschlag
unterbreitet wie wir dafür sorge tragen
dass die wieder vom trittbrett runter
geschubst werden er besteht im kern
darin dass nachgewiesen werden muss dass
die unternehmen systemrelevant für
deutschland sind also dass sie einen
anteil an der gasversorgung haben der
nicht oder schwer zu kompensieren ist
zweitens dass der anteil der
ersatzbeschaffung von russischem gas
relevant im unternehmensportfolio sein
muss und nicht leicht kompensiert werden
kann durch andere geschäftsmodelle die
man ebenfalls hat andere energie
portfolios oder andere gas liefermengen
dazu kommt wie es immer ist wenn
deutschland wenn der staat den
unternehmen hilft dass man auf boni und
dividenden verzichtet und weil die
konstruktion dieser firmen manchmal
schwer zu durchschauen sind mutter
töchter nachgeordnete gesellschaften
muss absolute transparenz herrschen also
alle bücher offen so dass dann nicht
geschmückt werden kann und wir sind uns
sehr sicher dass wir schon mit diesen
maßnahmen dafür sorge tragen können dass
das was die deutsche öffentlichkeit die
letzten vier fünf tage so aufgewühlt hat
dann auch geklärt wird und diese
unternehmen ihre ansprüche wenn sie dann
noch aufrechterhalten werden nicht
gewährt bekommen ja am auf höhe der
deutschen gesellschaft war er natürlich
ganz besonders beteiligt das war auch
wieder interessant zu sehen wie man
robert habeck offenbar die regelrecht
beim denken zusehen kann follower
das was herr bolder jetzt gerade nicht
wenn da was forderungen auch aus der
seite der wirtschaft der industrie kommt
ist ja dass man eigentlich diese gas
umlage aus dem haushalt finanzieren
sollte das heißt als staatshilfe
klingt aber so ein bisschen nach fass
ohne boden sind ich die einzige ausgabe
die wir tätigen müssen und das würde ja
möglicherweise auch der
bundesfinanzminister die haare zu berge
stehen lassen wäre das aber trotzdem
eine alternative zu sagen statt dieser
gas umlage die ja möglicherweise wenn
man gleich auch darüber sprechen
ungerechtigkeiten gar nicht vermeiden
kann diese gas und lag durch eine solche
steuerliche
steuerfinanzierte hilfe zu ersetzen muss
dazu sagen das ist schon eine
steuerliche komponente gibt also der
konzern juniper das größte problem ist
für den wurde ja schon ein rettungspaket
geschnürt 15 milliarden euro es gibt
kredite der kfw die jetzt muss man sich
noch einmal aufgestockt werden der staat
will mit 30 prozent einsteigen also da
ist zum ist der steuerzahler schon mal
mit drin die gasanlage soll ja jetzt ab
oktober dann den großteil der mehrkosten
quasi ersetzen die juniper und co haben
weil sie halt ersatz für das russische
gas was uns fehlt wo anders beschaffen
müssen aber natürlich wäre es eine
überlegung gewesen zu sagen wir machen
dass das ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe wir
warten jetzt quasi die fehler unserer
energiepolitik der vergangenen jahre aus
und wir machen das zu 100% aus dem
haushalt man hat sich jetzt dagegen
entschieden ich bin skeptisch dass die
umlage also dass die regierung jetzt
tatsächlich von der umlage noch einmal
abrückt auch wenn die union das er laut
fordert und es ja auch aus der spd schon
stimmen gab dass man das vielleicht
einmal grundsätzlich in frage stellen
muss
der erste oktober rückt näher
finanzbedarf das da also ich vermute mal
dass weiter an dieser umlage
herumgedoktert wird aber auch das
wasserwerk heute angekündigt hat löst
halt nur einen teil der probleme das
nämlich auch wirtschaftlich gesunde
unternehmen die jetzt nicht in
existenznot sind aus dieser umlage geld
bekommen aber es sind noch etliche
andere baustellen die jetzt noch nicht
geklärt
äußerungen die hatte er heute nicht zum
ersten mal gemacht mit dem trittbrett
fahrern die man jetzt vom trittbrett
stoßen soll wie ist das eigentlich muss
man sich das vorstellen ist das wirklich
richtig so möglich gas umlage dass man
sagt ja es muss auch gleichheit unter
allen unternehmen herrschen die zb
bisher russisches gas vertrieben haben
aber einige eben wesentlich besser
dastehen als die anderen dass wir sagen
aber wir sind ja genauso betroffen was
können wir dafür dass wir so einen
geschäftlichen erfolg haben kann man
diese trittbrettfahrerei unterbinden ich
glaube das ist ja mal ein bisschen
schwierig also aus
unternehmensperspektive ist das gar
keine trittbrettfahrerei sondern die
verantwortung den aktionären gegenüber
ja also die sind ja verpflichtet so was
in anspruch zu nehmen wenn sie da ein
recht darauf haben ich glaube dass wir
müssen uns einfach klarmachen wir sind
in einer wirklich besonderen situation
ich persönlich finde manche wie die
manche konflikte ausgetragen werden
momentan ein wenig kleingeistig ich
glaube es hängt auch ein bisschen
zusammen mit mit der nächsten wahl in
niedersachsen auch damit zusammen mit
den schlechten ergebnissen einiger teile
der koalition bei den vergangenen
landtagswahlen
und und das hängt natürlich auch damit
zusammen dass es einfach verdammt
schwierig ist wir führen gerade einen
wirtschaftskrieg gegen russland
und letztendlich ja nicht nur den
sondern auch noch sind wir ja irgendwie
auch noch durch waffenlieferungen
beteiligt an dem direkten konflikt und
das ist nunmal einfach eine ganz
besondere situation und da gibt es keine
einfachen lösungen und und es gibt
einfach einen rechtlichen rahmen in dem
sich politik bewegen muss und also am
liebsten ich weiß nicht wie das hier
eine runde ist hätten wir doch
eigentlich alle dass das eine über
gewinn steuer gibt dass man genau diese
ich sage mal diese trittbrettfahrer
irgendwie sauber abziehen kann und das
ist aber auch total kompliziert und da
gibt es eben auch streit in der
koalition darüber aber so wie er es in
einer idealen welt weil jetzt ja ganz
verschiedene also zum beispiel auch
ökostromanbieter machen jetzt plötzlich
mit ihrem strom total kasse einfach
nicht weil die böse sind sondern einfach
weil der strommarkt so funktioniert ja
also das ist nicht weil es geht sondern
weil es passiert der ist so der ist so
gebaut dass wenn der teuerste anbieter
von extra strom einen bestimmten betrag
braucht dann kriegt ihn jeder der
ebenfalls extra strom in dem moment
eine einfache saubere lösung wäre da
würde ich jetzt auch das ist halt
machen probiert ich hoffe dass ganz kurz
noch auseinanderhalten es gibt ja diese
was ich jetzt angesprochen die
sogenannte merit order dass nämlich das
teuerste teuerste gasanbieter quasi den
strompreisen auch mit beeinflusst das
soll jetzt entflochten werden das geht
aber gar nicht so schnell dass für den
laien klingt das auch wahnsinnig
kompliziert glauben sie dass die bleiben
noch kurz bei der gartenanlage dass die
letztendlich vor gericht landet und dass
das dann sich möglicherweise in einem
noch größeren chaos auch für die
menschen ende die dann gar nicht mehr
wissen was eigentlich mit dieser mit
dieser idee dann passiert und was dafür
vor allen dingen für sie selbst bedeutet
also ich habe also die angst dass das
ganze was immer da jetzt kommt wenn ich
also die diskussion sehr dass wir jetzt
erstmal differenzieren wollen wir
unterstützen in der nächsten runde was
hat prinzipiell auch vor dem
gerechtigkeit
merkmal ja auch richtig wäre habe ich so
meine zweifel dass wir am ende etwas
hoch komplexes haben was auch wieder
tatsächlich in den verwaltungen landet
also wieso aber gucken dass das zieht ja
dinge nach sich und ich verstehe nicht
also was ich tatsächlich verstehen wie
gesagt ich bin kein kein energieexperte
aber als ich nicht verstehe es zu sagen
gibt es da diesen vorschlag 80% gaspreis
decke 20 prozent zu den jetzigen preisen
da haben wir den sparanreiz drin der für
alle im raum steht auch wir machen das
jetzt gerade wir drehen auch unsere
runden in der wir haben 1500 mann
verwaltung also auch wir können unseren
beitrag leisten und ich finde über das
energiesparen zu reden und da bin ich
ganz bei ihnen wir sollten auch nicht so
eine sonne sondern verweichlichte
debatte draus machen ja wir müssen jetzt
mal energiesparen dass er dafür hätte
niemand erfährt niemand tot um aber wir
müssen wir müssen die grundlage dafür
legen dass das familien mit dem was sie
dann am ende bezahlen sondern wirklich
klarkommen und die und die die angst
habe ich dass wir das was dass wir das
nicht rechtzeitig hinbekommen und wenn
sie in unsere breiten schauen dort
sammeln sich die ersten demonstrationen
und das wird innerhalb wenn wir jetzt
nicht aufpassen der nächsten wochen in
kürzester zeit eine bewegung und wir
brauchen einfach antworten also wir
müssen einfach eine position dazu haben
und ich möchte ganz weil mir das ganz
wichtig ist wir dürfen
auch nicht daraus zieht debatte werden
dass und das ist ja gerade so der
sächsische tenor der damit reingekommen
ist der mich sehr ärgert wir dürfen auch
keine die oder wird debatte draus machen
weil das was wir jetzt haben hier ist
nicht nur nicht nur folge des ukraine
konfliktes da muss man sich auch mal
ehrlich machen also dass das wird ein
riesen inflation haben dass wir dass wir
viele probleme haben da gibt es ganz
viele bausteine natürlich ist der
jetzige konflikt auch ein treiber aber
nicht allein ich also dass wir dass wir
das mit inflationsraten zu tun haben die
exorbitant sind das hat noch eine
längere geschichte und ich werde mich
auch dagegen die aktuelle
bundesregierung jetzt mal unabhängig
davon ob ich mit dem mit dem ergebnis
dieser arbeit gerade einverstanden bin
oder nicht aber es gehört auch zur
wahrheit dass die gerade etwas ausbaden
was auch schon sich länger zusammenrührt
und ich finde das gehört zur
sommerdebatte und das wird viel verkürzt
und das ist das gefährliche weil es am
ende zur politischen stimmung
zusammenrührt die uns wahrscheinlich am
ende einig sie haben damit sprechen die
lieferketten probleme an
rohstofflieferungen auch durch die
pandemie durch die korona weltweit
ausgelöst das thema was ich jetzt
angesprochen haben auch was die
soziale frage angeht das thema ist ja so
komplex dass wir selbst mit 45 minuten
in der phoenix runde lang darüber
diskutieren das nicht in einer sind im
unterkriegen das entlastungspaket morgen
in der phoenix runde ich nehme an dass
sie gerade etwas leichten körperlichen
schmerz empfunden hammer bohrer als sie
den begriff über gewinn steuer gehört
habe wenn aber jetzt wie herr urbach das
ja gerade geschildert hat der merkt
letztendlich das entscheidende
instrument ist gerade auch bei der
energieversorgung müssen dann nicht
gewinne die sozusagen
als windfall profits angefallen sind als
sogenannte zufalls gewinne bei denen die
die regenerativen
energie produzieren die regenerative
energie produzieren die unternehmen die
wenig kosten haben dass da ein ausgleich
geschaffen werden muss auch durch eine
sogenannte über gewinn steuer der
spanische regierungschef war ja heute in
meseberg haben wir schon gemacht bei uns
läuft das so ist das
muss ich da nicht die industrie die
wirtschaft auch auf diese diskussion
einlasse natürlich wir lassen uns auf
jede diskussion ein und sie können sich
vorstellen bei 3,6 millionen mitgliedern
dass wir dazu auch unterschiedliche
meinungen haben ich finde es aber
wichtig sich die wirkung mal genauer
anzugucken von so eine über gewinn
steuer ist hängt dann natürlich auch
ganz viel von meiner einzelheit ab wann
hat jemanden über gewinne als waren wird
wird es definiert und so weiter im
detail liegt der teufel das ist klar
aber grundsätzlich führt so eine über
gewinn steuer dazu dass natürlich die
unternehmen die diese zusätzliche steuer
bezahlen müssen und wer viel gewinne
macht führt auch viel körperschaftsteuer
ab das gehört eben auch zur wahrheit
dazu es ist nicht so dass die das alles
in ihre tasche stecken und damit ist das
geld weg und der steuerzahler sieht nie
was davon so ist es ja definitiv nicht
das führt aber dazu eine solche steuer
dass weniger mittel auch für
investitionen da sind und ich wir wollen
ja 2045 klimaneutral sein dann brauchen
wir insbesondere investitionen im
bereich der stromerzeugung wind
fotovoltaik als stichworte und diese
investitionen werden natürlich
schwieriger wenn die unternehmen damit
rechnen müssen der staat greift ein und
schöpft möglicherweise teile meiner
gewinne ab also solche gewinne haben
eine ganz wichtige funktion auch in der
marktwirtschaft nämlich das unternehmen
die lage versetzt werden zu investieren
weil das gut offensichtlich entsprechend
nachgefragt hause schwächen und die
marken er nicht vorausgesagt die
marktwirtschaft an der stelle
funktioniert nicht mehr wirklich ja wenn
sie eine marktwirtschaftliche system
haben das gebaut ist für normale zeiten
und sie haben keine normalen zeiten und
das marktwirtschaftliche system
funktioniert nicht
das tennis haben sich die lebensraum in
die lösung sich dann sozusagen
zurückzulehnen und zu sagen na ja das
sind halt gewinne und da soll man sich
mal nicht so haben und es gibt ja auch
ein bisschen körperschaftsteuer das
finde ich ein bisschen zwei so unsere
die steuereinnahmen des staates sind im
moment so hoch wie nie weil wir eben
weil die unternehmen gute gewinne
erzielen und die versteuert werden also
diese über gewinn steuer ist auch
einfach so ein symbol geworden sondern
dem motto es ist geht ungerecht zu und
die da oben die verdienen und das muss
jetzt irgendwie abgeschöpft werden es
ist unheimlich schwierig es ist
unheimlich schwierig so etwas umzusetzen
wie viel das bringt wissen wir nicht die
länder die damit experimentieren am
große probleme das durchzusetzen also
das ist mir die deutschen neigen
manchmal dazu über so details die einen
großen symbolwert haben uns ganz lange
auszutauschen aber nicht darauf zu
achten dass wirklich jetzt helfen würde
und ich glaube da müssen wir einfach
schauen wie über gewinnt steuer wird
nicht unsere probleme lösen ja und was
ist kann sein wenn wir gucken auf die
finanzkrise wie das war ja da wurde ja
auch lang und breit und warum müssen wir
jetzt die bank retten und jene und wer
muss dass am ende alles bezahlen hinten
dran nachdem die finanzkrise vorbei war
hat man sich natürlich von seiten des
gesetzgebers rangemacht europäisch ja
und deswegen an der stelle plädoyer wenn
wir was machen die dem fall eine
europäische massnahme das ist für den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland immer
die bessere variante als wenn wir
national und was machen es heißt immer
das ist nicht kommt das heißt es eben
nicht dass es nicht kommt weil schauen
sich die finanzkrise an danach hat man
ja den finanzsektor regulierte kann man
immer darüber streiten war das gut war
das schlecht hat etwas gebracht hat
nichts gemacht dass eine andere debatte
aber man hat das gemacht und das wird
sicherlich auch im energiebereich kommen
und dann kann man am ende zu der wenn
man sich verschiedene maßnahmen an guckt
sie immer gesagt dass für liegen
verschiedene maßnahmen auf den tisch
dann kann man am ende sicherlich zu den
gedanken kommen okay vielleicht ist dann
dass das was hilft hier dass die märkte
besser funktionieren das mag ja sein
aber einfach undifferenzierten über
gewinn steuer zu fordern ohne zu zumal
man fängt dann einen über gewinn also
wisst ja dass jetzt die lage heute die
arbeit die man dann leisten muss aber
das ist ja genau das umgekehrte zu
zurück das ist ja lustig weil weil du in
deiner habig macht diese gasse umlage
das sind mathe als verordnung schlank
schnell clean dann hat man natürlich die
drag gefechte und alle sind und sagen na
ja eine tolle ordnung zu machen ist halt
einfach das schnellste was eine
regierung machen kann und so eine sache
anzupacken und dann sagen alle da sind
aber schwierigkeiten das passt nicht das
ist schwierig das ist schwierig denn
wird das angepasst und sind irgendwie
immer noch alle sauer sozusagen ja aber
denn weg wie läuft sind jetzt richtig
ist jetzt eine verordnung richtig ist
jetzt ein gesetz richtig wollen wir es
fundamental richtig anpacken wollen wir
etwas praktisches machen ich glaube dass
all das schwierigste ist das hier alles
zerredet wird und am ende des tages ist
es doch so der staat wird enorm viel
mehr ausgaben haben wir haben dass wir
sie haben das wäre ein crooner gesehen
wir sehen ist jetzt müssen sie schon
deswegen machen weil wir diesen sozialen
frieden brauchen weil wir sonst als land
diese krise nicht durchhalten und das
ist und das ist von absolut großer
bedeutung und ich glaube nicht dass das
mal eben so geht ohne so ein paar dinge
anzupacken die einem also die auch
ungemütlich gerade ideal verdacht eines
symbol diskussion führen das beste gegen
diskussion ist immer dass man sich
überlegt was bedeutet das jetzt
eigentlich für die menschen da sind sie
ganz nah dran dann heißt das ja ihre
unruhe auch noch weiter angestachelt
dann können sie auch gleich was dazu
sagen was diese ganze diskussion gut wir
haben jetzt gas und war aber über
gewinnt steuer es gibt noch andere
wichtige gegen schüren wie nehmen die
menschen das war und was kommt da
eigentlich auf sie zu es gibt auch noch
kommunale energieversorger die da auch
noch involviert sind die viele menschen
versorgen mit energie mit fernwärme oder
eben mit den anderen energieträgern was
ist da eigentlich gerade auf der
kommunalen ebene und bei den menschen
los also ich glaube dass das größte
problem gerade die unsicherheit ist und
ich glaube auch dass der bürger und
ich glaube das ist eine binse der bürger
darf erwarten dass diese
hochspezialisierte start und dieses
system eine lösung fabriziert der bürger
ist nicht des bürgers aufgabe werden zu
können ob das eine über gewinn steuer
ist oder der garstige oder what else
fakt ist dass die leute wirklich
existenznöte haben ich komme aus einer
gegend da ist es mit eigenkapital runter
wirtschaft hat sich sommers gut bestellt
wir haben ein riesenproblem wir haben
und wir haben privathaushalte die die
fragen mich irgendwie komme ich über den
winter komme ich über den winter wird
das gas geben pflegeeinrichtungen die
uns jetzt fragen was ist denn wenn wenn
wir nicht mehr heizen können was machen
wir was machen wir unsere mit unserer
bewohner ganz pragmatische dinge auf die
ich momentan keine antwort habe und ich
eigentlich immer nur hoffen kann dass
der fall nicht eintritt also das was
irgendwie hinbekommen dass zumindest
eine grundversorgung da ist das ist das
was der bürger erwartet und das ist die
angst die ich auch habe weil das
natürlich und da ist stichwort soziale
frieden ist gefallen zu recht die leute
dann auf die straße gehen und ich habe
die angst davor dass das diese
gerechtfertigten proteste die dann
entstehen würden von den von den
falschen geändert werden und dann haben
wir ein richtiges problem und ich finde
und unter gehörig auch häufiger und das
ist auch zulässig solche vergleichenden
debatten anzustellen zu sagen wir haben
wir haben 100 milliarden sondervermögen
wenn es um die rüstung geht und wenn es
um die existenzielle frage geht vor der
ich gerade mit meiner familie stehe dann
gibt es keine antwort ich finde wir
brauchen eine antwort wie immer die
aussieht aber wir brauchen im klaren
klar das ist muss dahin ja es muss eine
grundsätzliche idee geben wie wir wie
wir über diesen winter kommen da wird
anschließend das problem gas mangel lage
drohende gasmarkt ja dann würde ich
jetzt gerne gleich drauf kommen vorher
aber noch ein ganz kurzer einschub wie
es dazu kommt oder bzw die man die
abwenden könnte wir hängen ja immer noch
in gewisser weise am russischen tropf
der zudem zwei wird ja zur nächsten
tagen noch mal abgeschaltet weil wieder
mal repariert werden muss glaubt
wladimir putin zwar kein mensch aber
wird so sein jetzt gibts sogar
forderungen vor aldi von alle von
protagonisten der öffentlichen
diskussion die auch sonst immer sehr
aufmerksam sind beziehungsweise sehr
viel aufmerksamkeit erregen wie wolfgang
kubicki oder sahra wagenknecht hier
ansagen als man möchte doch bitte die am
boden der ostsee liegende pipeline
trotzdem zwei die ist fertig öffnen dann
hätten wir das problem nicht ist das
eine option oder hätte das verheerende
konsequenzen immer darauf eingehen das
ist nun wahrlich keine option also das
ist eine vermeintlich einfache lösung
die aber nicht also ja so zumindest aus
meiner sicht völlig indiskutabel ist wir
müssen versuchen eben was wir im moment
schon machen aus anderen ländern
möglichst viel gas heran zwischen ganz
auf dem markt ja natürlich ist genügend
gas auf den markt es gibt
flüssiggastanker die momentum richtung
asien unterwegs waren und umkehren weil
wir in europa gerade den markt leer
kaufen und die höchsten preise zahlen
was wiederum auch ein problem ist weil
in europa gerade das ganze gas hortet
also wir bekommen gas aber das problem
ist halt das ist ein sehr teures gas
also auf die diskussion geht man noch
dazu die infrastruktur und das russische
gas ist reicht von einfachen das
entsprechend umzustellen bisher kam das
gas vorwiegend von osten jetzt kommt es
eben von norden beziehungsweise
nordwesten als an den küsten angelandet
wird wir haben nicht die infrastruktur
das nach süden nach osten oder die hat
ja auch kein billiges russisches gas
kauft
roller hat gesagt das war jetzt
politische indiskutabel sind was genauso
warum jetzt also alle alle die sagen das
xoom 2 in betrieb nehmen die sollen sich
mal angucken die gas flüsse durch die
pipeline die in bayern ankommt da haben
wir noch nie irgendwas von turbinen
problemen oder irgendetwas gehört die
vollzieht aber die flüsse von nord
stream 1 genau nach als nord stream 1
auf 40 prozent gegangen ist ist die auf
40% gegangen als nord stream 1 im juli
bei 0 war war die auch bei 0 jetzt ist
im moment auch bei 20 also das ist doch
das beste beispiel dafür
dafür dass wir ein wirtschaftskrieg sind
und dass herr putin mit und spielt warum
soll das dann nicht mehr trotzdem zwei
genauso machen gut das wäre ja die frage
gewesen sollte damit natürlich auch
erpressen kann das heißt also dass uns
russisches gas nicht wirklich aus der
also es gibt ja auch jetzt erste länder
die sagen sie hier und genau verzeichnet
von uns auf russisches gas gut die sind
auch nicht so davon abhängig wie wir das
jetzt waren aber es geht ja schon in die
richtung wir sind ja schon deutlich
weniger abhängig von dem russischen gas
aber was er schon zu recht gesagt hatte
wir kommen nicht über den winter mit dem
was in den speichern ist nimmt wenn sie
einmal gefüllt sind es reich zuvor
zweieinhalb drei monate wenn wir sparen
vielleicht auch ein titel länger aber
die deutschen winter sind gewöhnlich
etwas länger sprich es muss parallel
auch gas eingespart werden und wir
kommen halt von diesen jetzt erst mal
von diesen hohen preisen so schnell
nicht runter und dafür müssen halt
lösungen gefunden werden und ich
verstehe ihren ihren unmut oder den
unmut der menschen total und ich glaube
das ist eines der großen probleme der
regierung im moment dass jeder oder
viele jetzt schon die hohen preise zu
spüren bekommen etwa indem die abschläge
aufgesetzt werden indem dieser umlage
jetzt konkret wird aber sie hat noch
nicht wissen was kommt denn da jetzt
dagegen also das was ist jetzt das
dritte entlastungspaket bis zu welcher
einkommensgruppe wird man profitieren
wie viel der mehrkosten werden ersetzt
werden und dieses vakuum das da gerade
entsteht das ist natürlich alles in dem
sehr viel frust wächst und deswegen muss
die regierung da aus meiner sicht auch
sehr schnell vielleicht ist es eine
sache ran darf also nochmal diese
gasanlage diskussion ich mich nämlich
eigentlich total ärgert wie gesagt weil
sich total an dem problem der
verbraucher vorbeigeht wenn ich
preisunterschiede von irgendwie sechs
center was ich eben genau aus dieser
studie gab es über 43 cent pro kilowatt
das sind ja das ist ja absurd und da
werden ja auch die menschen total
unterschiedlich belastet und ja
eigentlich fast nach dem zufallsprinzip
ja also ob sie irgendwie das glück
hatten einen grundversorger zu geraten
der gerade für etwas längere zeit
abgeschlossen hat oder das pech an ein
der das kurs- oder die oder vielleicht
haben sie auch einfach
ist haben sie sogar gewinne gemacht
haben bisschen was von ihrem bereits
gebunkerten gas verkauft also weiß ich
gar nicht wie sowie das immer zu den
hohen preisen kommt also eigentlich
müsste die gasanlage viel höher sein und
müsste dafür sorgen dass alle mehr oder
weniger dasselbe zahlen das wäre
eigentlich eine maßnahme die die
wirklich zu einer gewissen gerechtigkeit
und auch so ein bisschen gewissen
sicherheit für viele leute führen können
ich habe gestern mit einem mit einem
freund gesprochen also ich bin jetzt bei
20 cent ist bei mir auch gerade erhöht
worden ja von sieben cent pro
kilowattstunde und guter freund von mir
ja mein vermieter hat gerade stolz
gesagt wir werden noch ein jahr lang für
13 kriegen ja dachte ich auch immer
super also das konnte sich gar nicht
glauben ich freue mich auch ob der
irgendwann das muss ich jetzt kündigen
weil das klappt doch nicht aber ich will
noch mal sagen also das ist doch nicht
das ist doch nicht fair und ich glaube
da wäre ein riesen wenn das so zu sagen
wenn man das an der tankstelle sehen
würde wenn die leute ihren gaspreis an
der tankstelle sehen würden dann wäre
hier schon längst ein aufstand im land
gut also die
gas ist teuer es muss aber auch genügend
gas da sein gas mangel lage war ja der
begriff jetzt gibt es ja da prioritäten
privathaushalte stehender ganz oben auf
der prioritätenliste
gesundheitseinrichtungen
pflegeeinrichtungen sozialeinrichtungen
wird es bei dieser rangfolge bleiben
sind die privathaushalte die menschen
selbst besonders geschützt das machen
sie die gaslieferung bei den
gaslieferungen so genau kann ich nicht
beantworten das wird die regierung
beantworten also grundsätzlich ist das
jetzt bisher das geld und die geltende
regel auch dann noch mal ran gegangen
wird ich keine ahnung das ist ja schon
animationen was du mit einem
gesetzesentwurf gestimmt sein weil es ja
eine europäische regelung und wenn sie
vorher gesagt haben ja dann wird sowieso
nichts dann müsste es wurde diskutiert
auch aber aus
der industrie sich zu überlegen was
nützt uns wenn wir waren mit der wohnung
sitzen aber hier massenarbeitslosigkeit
haben weil die betriebe alle dicht
machen wie ist ihre situation ist diese
ist sie zu starre diese diese rangfolge
oder wie sollte die industrie im winter
da auch berücksichtigt also ich glaube
erst mal ist es ganz wichtig und das ist
ja auch schon angeklungen dass wir nur
gemeinsam über die lage kommen also
jetzt irgendwie hingegen irgendwie ein
anderes haushalte gegen unternehmen
handelsunternehmen gegen industrie wen
auch immer gegeneinander auszuspielen
damit kommt man nicht weiter wir müssen
alle einsparen das ist glaube ich mal
die erste priorität
es wird aus meiner sicht so laufen wenn
wir tatsächlich in der gast mangel lage
reihen laufen und das ist ja mit einer
gewissen ansage auch als wir haben einen
gewissen vorlauf dann werden die preise
so durch die decke gehen dass wir uns
wünschen dass wird die aktuellen preise
noch mal hätten das ist meine
persönliche prognose was wiederum dazu
führt dass industriebetriebe weil die ja
häufig direkt an diesen preisen
inzwischen dran hängen also die zahlen
den tagesaktuellen preis direkt ihre
produktion einstellen im übrigen auch
immer viele gar nicht ihre gasmengen
geordert haben auch für das laufende
jahr noch sie kriegen wenn sie hier wenn
sie jetzt heute ein etwas länger
laufenden gas kontrakt wollen kriegen
sind teilweise gar nicht mehr sie müssen
sie also tatsächlich tagesaktuell
eindecken zum tagesaktuellen preise
kriegen also das preissignal wenn man da
nicht bei 250 euro sind so wie gestern
bei 500 euro spüren sie das direkt und
wir sehen jetzt schon dass bereits eine
industrie in den ersten sieben monaten
dieses jahres einen
wertschöpfungsverlust von 20 milliarden
euro stattgefunden hat das heißt wir
sind hier in deutschland 20 milliarden
euro ärmer geworden mit den ganzen
effekten bei den beschäftigten mit den
effekten bei den zulieferern mit den
effekten bei den dienstleistern die dann
noch dranhängen effekte sind natürlich
noch größer ist diese 20 milliarden und
wir stehen ja erst am anfang das ist die
situation vor der wir stehen und
deswegen habe ich gesagt ja am anfang
die lage ist wirklich dramatisch und wir
machen uns massive riesige sorgen sieht
also die versorgung gar nicht mehr so
als problem als vielmehr die kreise im
moment sind definitiv die preise die
versorgung also das konnten die preise
dadurch etwas niedriger zu halten indem
man spart sparmaßnahmen gibt es ja auch
ist ja auch auffällig gewesen aber das
erzähle ja aber jetzt sehen wir noch mal
eine typische kleinstadt wie wie die der
ich wohne da gibt es zwei bäcker die
beiden bäcker können auf gas nicht
verzichten wenn ich die rechnung gemacht
habe wenn ich den folgen kann dann weiß
ich was das mit dem mit dem brot und
brötchen preisen macht dazu die
steigerung die jeder zu hause auf seinem
haushalt liegen hat mit der ungewissheit
ob sie überhaupt ins ziel kommt wo soll
das hinführen also dass das ist wahr
dass das ist im kreis ich allen zugute
wenn sie tatsächlich effektiven ich
wollte jetzt nicht auf die speziellen
fall eingehen wir haben ja im sommer das
lag sicherlich auch an better und
relativ viel gespart deswegen die
speicher auch relativ schnell voll es
gibt jetzt diese sparmaßnahme die zum
teil ab september gelten dass in
öffentlichen gebäuden als auch im
landratsamt mittelsachsen nur noch bis
19 grad geheizt werden darf die
swimmingpools die privaten dürfen nicht
mehr mit gas oder mit strom beheizt
werden die straßenbeleuchtung wird ein
geschenk nicht die beleuchtung an sich
die straßen beleuchtet um die
verkehrssicherheit herzustellen sondern
leuchtreklame und auch das anstrahlen
von denkmälern sinnvoll ausreichend was
da ja sind wir aber auch da würde ich
sagen ist dass vieles symbolisch also
durch das was all dieser einzelmaßnahmen
die sie gerade aufgezählt haben wird
geschätzt dass man ungefähr zwei bis
drei prozent des gasverbrauchs dadurch
einsparen kann das ist auch wichtig jede
kilowattstunde zählt aber auch das ist
jetzt nicht der weisheit letzter schluss
sondern das ist wir müssen insgesamt
tatsächlich auch jetzt jenseits des
verordnungswege es werden die
verbraucher wahrscheinlich eben weil die
preise so hoch sind dann schon von sich
aus auch die wohnung etwas kälter
einzelne zimmer vielleicht nicht mehr
heizen also damit da wird viel passieren
was jetzt nicht in die angeordnet wird
oder nicht staatlich verhängt wird
einfach weil die preise so hoch sind
dass sowohl die betriebe als auch die
privathaushalte jetzt schlecht weniger
heizen können wenn sich hin wie die
produkte
genau die aber die hat ihre produktion
zum teil schon drosseln was nicht gut
ist aber was also was auch dazu führt
dass wir jetzt wieder tatsächlich etwas
mehr gas in den speichern haben eben
weil jetzt schon weniger verbraucht hat
das alles nicht erfreulich das ist
rezession ist unausweichlich
voraussichtlich also wenn wir uns die
daten so angucken und die preise so hoch
bleiben und dafür spricht ja alles also
dass wir auf einem niveau zurückgehen
dass wir eine corona zeiten war
natürlich auch nicht normale zeiten aber
vor corona da haben wir über 20 euro je
megawattstunde beim gas gesprochen dass
wir dahin zurückkehren das wird
voraussichtlich bis 2030 nicht der fall
sein werden langfristig mit deutlich
höheren preisen konfrontiert sein beim
gas sie hatten angesprochen das war
natürlich ein wichtiger eckpfeiler des
wirtschaftsstandorts deutschland dass
wir dieses relativ billige russische gas
bekommen haben das ist weg und wenn sie
sich angucken in den usa haben sie den
endkundenpreis gas der wir sind von der
region ab aber bei 20 euro je
megawattstunde liegt sie haben die
zahlen also im moment ein zehntel oder
noch weniger von dem was wir in
deutschland bezahlen unsere
auslandshandelskammern registrieren
massives interesse aus deutschland an
produktionsverlagerungen in die usa
damit wären wir uns auseinander setzt
aber das ist eigentlich in mittelsachsen
fracking gaben
an dass es sich heldt nein das ist doch
nicht das ist doch auch eine falsche
diskussion vielleicht muss man auch in
deutschland irgendwann mal lernen dass
wir dass wir
tatsächlich an einer zeitenwende stehen
und dass wir auch eine andere aufgabe
haben nämlich den umbau dieses landes
dann wenn ich jetzt also wir haben alle
möglichkeiten dafür dann müssen wir
jetzt angehen also dass man kann jetzt
natürlich das beklagen stimmt daher zu
teilen auch mit ein aber das wird zu
wenig also jetzt den mond anzuhalten und
zu sagen wir werden alle sterben nutzt
da nichts also vielleicht kann man auch
ausnahmsweise in einer krise meine
chance entdecken und das würde bedeuten
dass wir mit den technologischen
fähigkeiten wir in diesem land haben
vielleicht tatsächlich auch den mal
vorwärts kommen und dem rest der welt
zeigen dass das geht wir haben alle
möglichkeiten dafür
zum beispiel dass man aber generell uns
ja jetzt auch helfen hätten wir die
letzten hätten wir die letzten 20 jahre
die erneuerbaren energien nicht so
sträflich vernachlässigt wer unser
problem ist auch klar dass kam ein hin
und her diskutieren da höre ich wieder
das entscheidende sondern ist es wird
auch nicht immer der wind dass das alles
kokolores und jeder der sich damit
befasst der weiß dass auch wir könnten
viel viel weiter sein und ein stück weit
zahlen wir jetzt auch die strafe dafür
dass muss man auch ganz klar sagen wenn
das auch eine illusion zu glauben dass
jetzt wenn wir jetzt den ausbau turbo
werfen dass wir dann im nächsten winter
schon keine probleme mehr haben sie
sorgen für eine längere zeit und da
werde ich von mehreren jahren wenn nicht
einem jahrzehnt und länger weiter auf
fossile energieträger angewiesen sein
die art und weise wie deutschland gerade
seine seinen quasi energieversorgung
selbst geschneiderten mir sagen wir dass
die atomkraftwerke vielleicht auch so
ein bisschen
jetzt war er wahrscheinlich sollten
heute zumindest aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium für das würde ja
auch ein strompreis industrie wohl etwas
regen haben sie die größenordnung wie
viel würde das wenn das 6 das ist weiter
läuft das ist reine spekulation was das
bringen würde der markt hat es natürlich
eingepreist dass sie zum 31.12 rausgehen
natürlich hätten wir den preiseffekt
aber wie hoch der tatsächlich ist das
hängt ja auch von vielen anderen
faktoren ab vom wetter wie sie in
frankreich aussieht da es sind ja sehr
viele kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet weil
es mal wieder regnet und die wasserkraft
wieder produzieren kann deswegen daten
eine prognose abzugeben welche wir
unterscheiden zwischen den kurzfristigen
sachen und den langfristigen sachen
jetzt die akw in den streck betrieb zu
nehmen ist halt eine kurzfristige hilfe
langfristig ist es ein akw ein problem
und keine lösung weil sie unglaublich
viel kapital für lange zeit binden und
und damit die alternativen behindern das
ist ja das ist ja immer bescheid müssen
wir auch jetzt nicht so tief einsteigen
ich würde eigentlich gerne noch mal auf
dass verbraucher thema zurückkommen
minute schossen die sendung
[Musik]
weil wir eben noch mal bei dieser frage
waren industrie versus verbrauche ich
finde es nämlich auch dass es wichtig
ist dass das auch bei den verbrauchern
das signal ankommt dass sie jetzt
wirklich alle sparen sollten und das ist
auch ein unterschied für sie persönlich
in der haushaltskasse macht wie sie mit
energie künftig umgehen und politik ist
normal oft sehr symbolisch und ich finde
es total gut dass sie das die kommunen
jetzt auch voraus gehen und sagen wir
machen dann auch hier und da das licht
früh raus und machen es bei uns kälter
damit das nicht mehr irgendwie so eine
absolute sache ist wo man für belächelt
wird sondern dass das eine gemeinsame
nationale anstrengung ist dann bringt es
noch mehr als diese 23 will die
inflation mehrfach jetzt hier schon
besprochen ist die eine richtige
gefahren auch für unsere stabilität
die sich möglicherweise da anbahnt
jänner also ich meine das ist ja eben
das problem nicht nur dass die
energiepreise steigen die treiben die
inflation besonders aber im wir haben es
ja auch bei lebensmitteln bei der
herstellung ja klar ist also gerade für
diejenigen die arbeiten aber wenig haben
und als ende glaube ich ist die
regierung jetzt schon unter druck
zusagen sowie helfen wir da dass
menschen nicht in armut rutschen eben
weil es so toll gerinnen und bürger und
unternehmen ja quasi in einem boot das
in ein brot genommen gut dann bedanke
ich mich bei ihnen ich bedanke mich bei
julia löhr byberg neubauer bei matthias
urbach und weil sebastian bohley ich
hab's liebe zuschauerin liebe zuschauer
vorhin schon angesprochen morgen werden
wir uns mit dem thema entlastungspaket
beschäftigen das soll ja möglicherweise
vorgezogen werden schon auf diese woche
einschließlich des koalitionsausschusses
der noch auf diese woche dann vorgezogen
werden soll aus genau diesem grund
morgen der phoenix hat der titel sorge
vor dem winter wer wird wie entlastet
jetzt folgt felix der tag mit maria
weber um 23 uhr und das thema das wir in
dem tag vor allen dingen behandelt
werden ist noch mal ausführlicher das
thema kabinettsklausur in meseberg da
ging es noch um einiges mehr als um die
gasanlage bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]